all right carolyn yes carolyn where'd
you grow up where are you from
originally around texas
and tell me about your childhood you had
both your parents when you were young
yes
[Music]
how did you describe your childhood
traumatic
i was in a fire
at five years old i got burnt
third degree burns my body
your your house burned
yes
and i was paralyzed
for three years when would you
for three years yes
you were the only one that was hurt in
the fire
yeah is the time
then another year later then my daddy
got burned under fire
so you lost your father also in a fire
yes
and when you say traumatic that you were
talking mainly about the
the fires and the
was there anything else going on
yeah this is my dad was older
he had a heater inside the house
the heater was the cause of the fires
yes
the pipes busted
[Music]
how would you how would you describe the
rest of your childhood after your father
passed
mentally unstable
how's that
i was put on psych meds
how old are you today
i'm 61 now 61. they had psych meds back
then
yes
[Music]
you know what you were taking at the
time
that latins
riddles
general
i don't know something like that
what kind of kid are you in school
i like to write
i like math science all subjects
you're a good student yes straight a
student
and after school what do you do with
your life
play baseball
do homework
but after after school
after you graduated what did you do
yes
i uh decided to go to phi camp here in
the state of california
fire camp is typically for kids that
have gotten in trouble yes i got in
trouble
what kind of trouble were you getting
into
fighting fighting
so you moved to california what age
23
thirty-three
do you have children
i have one
did you raise your kid yes my mother did
the rest
anyways until you got 15.
and then what happened
then i started in trouble
he did i did you do yes what kind of
trouble are you getting into drugs
assault with little living
that'll do that
[Music]
so you do some prison time
yes
how many years did you do
four
and after you got out you came here to
skid row
no i lived in englewood
have you been on skid row for how many
years
27 27 years you've been here
where do you stay now you're in a tent
yes
nicely i'm sorry nicely
we're using uh some of the drugs that
are out here
alcohol mostly
how calls here
oh yes yes cold years
it's nine in the morning have you had
one yet no not yet oh yeah
how much beer will you drink a day
265
that'll do it yeah yeah
[Music]
do your friends down here
some
what would you say is your biggest
regret in your life
my auntie
sorry
my auntie
goodman cause she tried she took uh us
away from my mom
louie's litter
so you wish you would have stayed with
your mom
yes
i went back after five years
why were you
taken away from your mom
because my mother can read or write
and it's the way her mother treated her
and i didn't like it
so i retaliated
snuck all the girls out the house at
night time at 10 am
[Music]
they rather find what mama was
and my auntie did wrong she's
you spray dogs you don't spay people
she had an assistant
pregnancy terminated
oh it is
lucky because you don't kill babies
babies are gifts
you were married before
come along
[Music]
what was the best time of your
at the life of 35
running track
writing
playing baseball
i write my own forms
what's been the worst time of your life
fire
[Music]
what are you worried about now
in your life
my son
are you religious
the i want to say
yes
christianity
[Music]
would you describe yourself as happy
at times
you get depressed or angry or
yes
how do you think the years that you
spent
living homeless has changed you
better for the better because i'm also
to myself
you stay to yourself now yes
it's best that way
i don't hurt people i hurt people
you you still have hope of getting off
the streets
sure
yes
it's time
there's something out there better
i'm sure there is
caroline what would you say is the most
important thing you've learned in your
life
that the word of god is the power of god
and you know overcoming the problems
circumstances i go through
i just got to put my trust all the way
in here not just halfway
you believe in power greater than myself
can restore my insanity
most of all practice what i've reached
all right carolyn thank you so much for
sharing your story nice you're very
welcome
i wish you the best of luck out there
all right thank you thank you
you